نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن وزاره الصحه
الايطاليه اكتشفها اصابه 50 فيلم ان
الركاب القادمين علمتني طائرتين من الصين
الى مطار ميلانو بفيروس كورونا وانها تجري
تحاليل اضافيه لاختبارات الفايروس
للمصابين واضافه الوكاله نقلا عن السلطات
الايطاليه انها في حاله اكتشافي متحولا
جديد من الممكن ان تفرض حضرا على القادمين
من الصين
اعلنت الولايات المتحده وانها ستطلب من
المسافرين القديمين من الصين اجراء فحص
كرونا لتنضم بذلك الى دول اخرى اتخذت
القرار نفسه بسبب ارتفاعه حالات الاصابه
في الصين وياسر القرار وبدايه من الخامس
من يناير المقبل
وسيطالب المسافرون بتقديم اختبار
نتيجته سلبيه خلال فتره ان تزيد عن يومين
من تاريخ السفر ويطبق القرار على كل
المسافرين القديمين من الصين الذين يبلغون
من العمر سنتين او اكثر ياتي هذا القرار
بعد ان قررت الصين انهاء الاجراءات
الصارمه التي كانت تتخذها في ايطاليا
سياسه صفر اصابه لمنع انتشار كورونا
وكانت الصين وقد عرضت عن ثقتها بتحقيق
انتصار شامل في معركه السيطره على جائع
كورونا وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان معدله
الوفيات بالفيروس في الصين هو الادنى
عالميا وان السلطات ستعيد النظام
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الى سابقي عهده مع
الحفاظ على صحه المواطنين وفي رد على وضع
واشنطن تدبر جديده على القادمين من الصين
الى اراضيها قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصيني انه يتعين على جميع الاطراف
التعاون لضمان يا سفر الامن للاشخاص من
مختلفه البلدان وان كان تسلطته الصينيه قد
علنتي الغاء الحجر الصحي على المسافرين
الوافدين الى البلاد ضمن اجراءات تخفيف
القيود المفروضه منذ ظهور الجارحه